Here is my Shirou plum tree. And after a
few years of patience, it's finally
bearing fruit for the first time. Shirou
plums are a Japanese variety known for
their sweet, juicy yellow flesh and mild
flavor. They're also one of the earliest
plums to ripen in the summer, usually
ready around July, depending on where
you live. These trees grow best in USDA
zones 5 through 9. Mine's here in zone
8b and it's been thriving with full sun,
good drainage, and regular
watering. Shirro plum trees can grow to
about 15 to 20 ft tall. However, with
pruning, you can easily keep them
smaller and more manageable. I'm keeping
mine between 6 and 8 ft tall. I do a bit
of light pruning in late winter to shape
it and let more light into the canopy. I
planted this tree about 3 years ago and
Chirro plums usually start producing
fruit in their third to fifth year after
planting. This one is just starting now
and it's a great reminder that sometimes
you just have to wait for the good
stuff. These are partially
self-pollinating, but they'll produce
much better with a compatible pollinator
nearby. Something like a Burbank or
Santa Rosa plum can really boost the
yield.
The fruit starts off green and gradually
turns a soft yellow as it ripens. You'll
know it's ready when the skin turns
golden and the fruit gives slightly to
the touch. They come off with a gentle
twist and are best picked just before
they're fully soft for the sweetest
flavor. Shirro plums are great for fresh
eating, but they also make amazing jams
and desserts. It's really been rewarding
to watch this tree grow and now finally
see the results. I can't wait to try
these plums and see what next year
brings.